so I have a problem and my my problem is
that I used them and to get them to do
anything remotely fancy or you know
customize it to my needs I need a V
Marcy and every time vim lags in a large
file or it's just a bit slower than I
would like I keep thinking about how
like I don't really need my vim to
handle every possible of MRC I just
needed to handle the VMRC that I have
and there's a whole bunch of
functionality in vim that I just I don't
even use right like there's a whole like
tab engine for example that like I just
don't care about it and the the only tab
settings that I use for my my tablet are
like four so why does it need to handle
like a tab length of three like who uses
tablets of three like you know this is
the kind of code that I would imagine is
inside them that goes okay like someone
said the tablet to for just like handle
it and insert the number of spaces
accordingly so I keep thinking about
what would be cool if I could just take
vim and take my vim RC and Jam IV Marcy
into my vim and just do a whole bunch of
like in lining and unrolling and simple
stuff and just throw away everything
else that I will never use so then at
the end of this I would have something
that's both smaller because it doesn't
have stuff I want to use and foster
because it doesn't have stuff I wouldn't
use right the idea of doing this in
general is called partial evaluation so
favorite example of this is so you think
of the program is taking static input
and dynamic input and static input is
essentially known in advance before the
program starts executing and dynamic
input is only known once the program
starts executing so and do you know to
produce some output so a favorite
example this is anything with a
configuration file you know I use vim
ours
I use vim but like Emacs is the same
problem like you know your web servers
so would it be cool if we could actually
just take the program and take the
static input and just jam it in like I
was describing and do simple
transformations like inlining constants
and unrolling loops so what does that
look like so going back to that example
I had earlier if the tablet is not used
anywhere else then I can just do that
right and that saves me a variable
lookup and it saves me like allocating
space that's not needed and all that all
that other fun stuff so that's constant
inlining and what about loop unrolling
so again same cord if I know that I'm
going to insert a space four times
why don't I just insert a space four
times pretty straightforward I think so
at the end of this I would have
something that's called a residual
program so you can think of this as
essentially evaporating away all the
parts of the program that I don't need
so it behaves exactly the same as my
original program on that static input
but it's Foster so the program that will
do this is called a specialized IRR so a
special laser takes a program and some
static input gems started comparing to
the program in lines it unrolls and does
some other simple program
transformations and then gives me a
residual program that can take only the
dynamic and put and produce the same
output that the original program would
have produced given the static and the
dynamic input so we call these programs
specialized errs and we say in the
terminology that a specialized or
specialized as a program with respect to
some input so I take it a slight detour
and let's talk about interpreters versus
compilers so Python for example is a
language that's usually interpreted and
an interpreter usually kind of looks at
instructions one by one and interprets
them it like changes its own state or
perform some action in the outside world
and these programs are relatively simple
to write but they're also slow because
they have to essentially consider each
instruction one at a time so in contrast
we have languages like C which are
typically compiled so a compiler will
kind of look at a whole source program
do a whole bunch of work and generate
another program that's usually in a
different language and these are hard to
read because it for one thing you have
to handle two different languages at
once but the output that they produce is
usually faster so wouldn't be nice if we
could have both we could have something
that's both simple to write as well as
fast enough for our purposes so a
researcher called your Chico food and
where I was talking about I was thinking
about these things in the early 80s
because what he wanted to do is he
wanted write software in basic which is
not the the fastest language interpreted
but he wanted the output to be fast like
Fortran but he didn't want write Fortran
so then he was thinking about this and
you thought okay so if I take an
interpreter and I specialized an
interpreter with respect to some source
program and then I do a whole bunch of
inlining unrolling order Vindicator
residual program that residual program
is essentially a cut-down version of the
interpreter that only knows how to do
the things that the source program knows
how to do and that can take whatever
dynamic input I need and produce some
output but this program that I've this
thing that I've created this residual
program does not have any dependence
on the old interpreter and runs by
itself so it's you we've created a
standalone program so that's pretty cool
we've compiled it somehow without
involving a compiler so talk about this
some more and you thought okay let's you
know let's let's take this one step
further what if you specialize the
specialized ER itself with respect to an
interpreter so you take a specialized ER
and you Jam an interpreter into it and
you do a whole bunch of inlining and
unrolling at the end of it you have
something that can then take some source
code that the interpreter knows how to
interpret and output and executable a
standalone executable just like in step
one so what we've done essentially is
we've made a compiler because that's
where the compiler does it takes a
program it takes some source code for a
program and outputs a standalone
executable so say the Python interpreter
is written in C and we have a
specialized no set of specialized C so
it takes the Python interpreter and
outputs something that can then take
Python source code and output a
standalone executable this is cool final
Trippi step
what do you specialize a specialized ER
so you take a specialized you take
another specialized er you download
specialized into the other the whole
bunch of in lying an underling and then
at the end of it you have a cool program
that can take any interpreter Lin
written in a language that the
specialized knows how to specialize and
I put an equivalent compiler so we've
made a compiler compiler that's pretty
cool pretty cool so why would someone
want to do this in in the 80s when your
cheek of food where I came up with these
ideas people want to head in was like
we're like okay let's write some
general-purpose specialized errs but it
turned out that they were very difficult
to write there no they're not easy
program stride and also the speed-up so
they provided weren't really as fast as
people are hoping for so still the idea
of specialization like gives us an
interesting insight into the difference
between interpreter and a compiler
because a specialized ER isn't either
but it's it's somewhere in between you
know the fact that you can use a
specialized or an interpreter to the
compiler is pretty cool which it means
it allows you instead of writing a
compiler which is sometimes hard and
error-prone tedious start by hand to
just write a compiler sorry an
interpreter which is relatively
straightforward and a specialized ER and
then john them together and get a
compiler for free so this is also
important when it comes to correctness
because you know compiler bugs are
pretty frustrating and if you just
didn't have to worry about that at all
they'll be pretty good
and so far I've avoided the use of the
word optimization but has what we've
been doing being optimization I would I
would argue yes so because you have to
stock the analyze a program I might do
some loop unrolling constant learning
and I think this is a good way of
thinking about what what optimization is
there a good entry point into learning
about those things if you're curious so
I mentioned that in the 80s I didn't
really go anywhere but in the present
day we have things like pie pie and
truffle and growl and LVM whose entire
value proposition is that if you write
your language a certain way then you can
get a just-in-time compiler for free and
was it just a time compiler but the
second food and we were projection it
essentially lazily partially evaluates
parts of your program in turns things
that were previously interpreted into
things that are not compiled and also
you know it just gives you faltered
programs like I still would like this
specialized bin I think we may be very
happy so that's essentially all I help
here's some resources there's a the
original paper here they'll be linked to
my slides following shortly the
Wikipedia page is always good there's a
much longer talk in which in some ways
this talk is a summary of called the
compilers for free that goes into
details and gives you in a sample
language to like talk about but you know
I think that talk is either 30 minutes
or 30 minutes or an hour long it's not
really have enough time for that there's
a textbook by the people who did some
interesting research into a partial
evaluation we're like hey you know
here's all the stuff for free some more
resources and then finally this really
interesting talk about 1/4 full demurrer
projection just going even further than
the three that we've covered just now so
this is yeah this is really all I want
you to take away from this talk and our
friend is like off so
[Laughter]
very much
[Music]